[Music]
last night we had an animal expert on
called david misajuski he's been here
before and he brought some very cool
animals to the show
now for the big finish to the segment uh
he wanted to bring out a water buffalo
okay
sounds fine right
well someone on my staff i haven't found
out who it is yet
thought it would be a really good idea
for me to get on the back of the water
buffalo
and ride it around
with absolutely no training
i repeat they said wasn't going to just
get on the water buffalo and they said
it in the morning meeting and i come in
they're like get on the buffalo so
i gave it a try during yesterday's
rehearsal
it did not go well
take a look
[Applause]
again
the water buffalo is fine if you're
worried about the water buffalo
we calculated i was about five feet in
the air yeah and i landed on this very
hard cement floor
on my hip okay now it really hurt it
really
effing hurt
but i did get something out of it the
greatest bruise of my life
i went home and i was about to get in
the shower and my two kids came in six
and eight and they saw the bruise and
they high-fived me they were like that
is awesome yeah yeah and my wife was
like that's amazing she said that is hot
we got it off
i've come to work today and i showed
that bruce to some people and they're
like everyone came to me like we got to
see this thing lines some people you
showed it to everybody i i showed it to
you and what did you think of it i it's
pretty amazing yeah it's a beautiful
shade of aubergine yeah
it's an amazing bruise i've never been
prouder of anything than i am drop trout
and show them right now
[Applause]
now i have one question were you gasping
at the bruise or the actual color of my
skin
[Applause]
i think half the people here were like
look how white his leg really is
[Laughter]
it has gone down the swelling yesterday
yesterday like a it was raised it was
like it was like a tennis ball sliced
one of those like purple potatoes and
shoved it on the side of your hip
i'm glad we did that yeah
that's going to be in the museum of
broadcasting one day we're going to get
a peabody award for that this will be
known as the age of conan's brews